hey guys how's it going welcome to ij
likes i'm justine that's my name let's
hiccups let's start the show
there's a lot of great videos this past
week it is father's day weekend week-ish
so celebrate all of you dads you adapt
your dad your dad's dad rhett and link
made a father's day rap my daddy
kidnapped himself and then escaped
instead of paying his own ransom next up
is this video by jimmy kimmel where he
does the baby bachelor
i love um
and now wesley travels across the
country to meet gabrielle's family
this i can watch it was cute but the
bachelor in bachelorette can't even
handle it going to choose me
but gabrielle's sister proves difficult
to win over i'm so excited for leslie to
meet my sister now this video i wish i
would have seen years ago because i
could have saved myself so many seconds
today i'm going to show you how to fold
a shirt
in under two seconds in second gaming
it's been a crazy past week it's been e3
so there has been so much controversy
over xbox first playstation and i'm
actually sick of hearing it i did
pre-order both so i can't wait till they
both arrive and i will be able to come
to my own conclusion how about this how
about i just enjoy playing games so i'm
going to play games on both of them and
have a good time
yeah also in gaming news a little more
casual of a game animal crossing ds new
leaf just came out
obsessed although i'm so sick of getting
sung by bees i'm so sick of shaking
trees and i don't want to pull any more
weeds also the last of us came out this
week it has been a great week for games
let me tell you i started playing i'm
halfway through and
i forgot i even had a pink
playstation controller it's pink
go figure i'm so mad that i have to go
out of town this week because all i want
to do is play games and i can't
last up is our fashion and beauty
segments which is probably my least
favorite because i never really have
anything to show you guys although i've
been using this hairspray lately it's
moroccan oil it's really light and i
always have terrible flyaways actually
i've got one right now it's always the
same piece of hair it says it's
weightless and a natural look i feel
real natural right now let me tell you
also these are pretty cute they are
iphone purse cases they're like really
flexible
it's kind of just made of a rubber the
only thing is come on guys why would you
make a purse iphone case and you can't
actually use it as a purse and that's
all i have for you guys in this episode
of ij likes i will see you soon um
yeah i'll catch you guys later bye
[Music]
you